attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
cette dernière claude bodin ski c'est
mon artiste préféré
ah non mais je m'en fous maintenant moi
je les juge sur facebook que tu étais
fan du gars du coup je me suis dit bah
ça va l'impressionner quoi ok c'est
gentil est bizarre de dire tu es très
belle aujourd'hui heureusement si tu me
dis parce que même si tu as manqué celle
que j'ai passé des heures à me coiffer
du michigan pour affiner ma taille et
plus cela pourrait monter les salaires
des fossiles
j'ai tellement m'adapter avec ses
chaussures c'est horrible ce qu'ils
savaient pas en tout cas bravo c'est
super bien fait un chapeau l'artiste
alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de mon
travail oit souvient la mère d'un vous y
comprend rien mais en fait 300 photos et
avec un pied très sur instagram
s'adonner à un truc sympa avec cette
oeuvre
j'ai voulu encourager les gens à braver
les interdits à transgresser les règles
a emprunté les routes de l'impossible
c'est bien la branlette tout ça
oui mes parents une auto école j'ai
juste récupérer un panneau et j'ai écrit
foncé dessus
franchement je suis capable de faire
pareil hein oui bien sûr allez y il ya
de la place pour tout le monde
le plus dur c'est pas de le faire c'est
de vendre vous vendez cinq mille balles
jia des cons qu'ils n'achètent 5000 je
vais pas me priver
enfin j'aime bien cette année ah oui
elle est très belle mais c'est quoi ça
symbolise un peu la mort et ce à une
sorte de fuite en avant vers la porte
avant le second tour
non c'est la sortie de secours
l'année dernière j'ai fait une
performance je me suis retrouvé 48
heures tout nu dans une vitrine à berlin
ouais j'avais envie de dénoncer la la
solitude moderne au sein de la
mondialisation des capitales européennes
et c'est complètement débile 13 essais
ça pour qu'on parle de moi alors bon oui
j'ai chopé une angine et j'ai fait trop
vite et de 20h hop le petit cookies mais
non non c'est simon oeuvre qui qui
montre que les européens laisse toujours
une petite part de gâteau à l'afrique
n'ont plus rien les petites structures
[Musique]